okay let's see ah Dutch I've had bad
things happen I've had bad things happen
when I played f5 and alrighty
I was just ready to play e6 I I'm I'm
just being real honest that was the
first thought I actually had right there
it's just playing it's play e6 yeah
let's do that let's do that okay let's
not do that let's play Knight f6 Oh
righty now I could play this if I really
want to or maybe I want to do this let's
try this
huh
then here can I get this moving in one
shot I'm gonna try for it
Tom Coach Bishop takes pawn takes me
writing what about pod push right now I
can get this in in one shot let's do it
what's the scoop what is the scoop here
if there's an opening I don't know a
whole lot about it's the opening called
the Dutch the one that I'm playing right
now let's take care I have a good Center
this knight on c3 I think I can take him
out of the ballgame by playing c6 and he
doesn't have a good square to go to
maybe Knight d5 is available but maybe
it's not those are fantastic pieces of
commentary right there did you pick up
on that one
I think d5 is a good move but maybe it's
not yeah let's keep going with that line
I was thinking that because of just c6
and then something with like Bishop
before later about c6 right now or just
Bishop here yeah if maybe I could just
take that yeah let's let's go for this
right now I'm not afraid of Knight d5 if
I'm gonna play Bishop b4 I'm doing it
with the intention of eventually killing
the knight it may be ruining their
structure and maybe I could rely upon
the c5 square if I'm gonna shatter the
Queen side structure here's one thing I
could rely upon c5 square I think now is
a time I need to throw a question to the
bishop and
I think what's necessary is Bishop takes
Knight as otherwise white either gets
stuck in a situation where one of two
things happens a the bishop is trapped
or B there's structural damage on the
Queen side it could be wrong though
because of issues on this diagonal the
Queen may be grabbing the pawn or coming
here with check etc let's see about some
things though throw question the bishop
for starters let's do it let's see what
white decides on and then only then will
I make my next move my next decision
only then will I run with my next plan
keep in mind that I am aware of the
pressure on f5 here and I'm
miscalculating if I take within my night
I'm dropping this I have to recapture my
queen
silly means okay alright well this night
is pinned I could maybe play here I
could well I should really take that
night now or if I want to preserve my
darks Tricia I don't take the night I
have to play c6
I think I liked c6 let's go with it
just constrain the night my bishop might
want to come back around here something
that would be a pretty good dog on a4
wouldn't it how's the center looking is
there enough control over it pawn push
how do I react to that pawn push here I
chase the night to maybe a better Square
maybe I think for starters castling is
good I do like this as a follow-up the
bishop can't play here coz a fork land
the bishop plays here I push here stop
the threat on this although actually
wouldn't even be a threat now that the
bishop is not guarding this Square this
move is all the more appealing because a
hits the knight be guards d3 and now
this acts as a support point I think the
bishop needs to run back don't know that
you can really tolerate a night landing
here additionally I am threatening c4 if
I play c5 I chased the night away but I
allow for Knight d5 I played here for a
reason and he's kind of just stuck there
I could land here with Czech I can also
grab here if I grab here I run it a
tricky stuff with the Knight takes pawn
I'm gonna do this instead and and then
as a follow-up
what oh you know what you know what I
have available to me
structural damage if the Queen takes I
could play here and now I can push that
night away and as a follow-up play my
bishop here there are is there's Queen
checks available on this on this side of
the board on the B file I just want to
get this pawn if I get this pawn that's
the game and I don't know that there's a
way that that could be prevented for a
second I thought that this is a threat
but my knight is there to watch over I
think the night with this type of
position I lost track of time as well
what happens from time to time to lose
track of time but anyhow I think this is
just intolerable a knight just held in
the hand not on the chess board is worth
the you know three points but when you
throw it in certain squares on the board
if it's too deep in your opponent's
position it starts to become worth a lot
more that's what we're seeing here it's
just too difficult to work around this
is an open file but as long as my knight
hangs around here there's nothing
exciting happening now that move okay
well there's tricks isn't there let's do
this the Knight has to go back and we
are Castleman opposite sides I could
have grabbed this pawn let's do it now
rook up and over is available this is a
passed pawn now oh I could have taken
the knight could have taken the night
after that pawn push
oh man what can you do yeah just grab
the pond
Jerry Jerry just got the pond yeah just
grab that pond because who needs a
knight right and you're clean is not
ready to get trapped is she can we just
trade please no that's a loser move it's
just full of here eighteen seconds give
a check hope for the best hope for the
best
don't take a night whatever you do know
you don't want to take a night god this
pond I just want to take that night you
just take that night okay get free over
here main to threat on the night tricky
stuff is winning but Wow
after a five a four I should have just
grabbed that night right there oh good
game let's hit the rewind let's flip the
board and let's take something away from
this hopefully all right right here
right here right now keep in mind what
it is white wants to do here what it is
what is it that white wants to do excuse
me what is it that black wants to do
let's get it right here black wants to
get an e5 in one shot so maybe you
should make black think twice about that
considered e5 before I'm able to get
this move in you can maybe look to me
get a knight on that square one day
Knight f3 d 4e six it's a sensitive
point in the Dutch defense it's one of
the one of the many weakened squares
that comes about as a result of playing
move one f5 as soon as you do this
what is slightly weakened c6 as soon as
I move this what becomes a whole eise
--ax sensitive point consider instead of
III considered e5 and then there's even
possibilities for your knight
I'm this square by way of h3 seems
awkward but
just a temporary post night h3 f4 and
maybe even one of these two if I'm going
to be pushing your bishop around there's
two holes be six and g6 where would a
knight like to be if both east six and
g6 have been weakened the answer
f4 because it eyes both of them so
that's just another thing to have in
mind
HC h6 is quite typical to see at some
point or another I don't know if I
should say typical it's natural-looking
enough I don't know if it's correct or
now but to just want to throw a question
that Bishop but that h3 to f4 Knight f3
the d4 one of these two squares having a
close eye on at d5 lending a support
point for your and ventral Knight tool
and they're all worth a closer look I
think things turn out to be just fine
here also I don't know that you really
benefit by exchange in here I think
keeping your pond right here maybe you
want to push maybe want to take keeping
guessing because what does this move do
which one of my pieces is helped out as
a result of this exchange and these are
things that you could be questioning and
when you are playing your own game how
does this benefit me you could ask
yourself how does this maybe benefit my
opponent by having this exchange it's
just equal material pawn for pond but
this is a more valuable pond being that
it's your only one you have present on
one of these for center squares and
additionally by having this exchange you
help black because of what guess which
piece has more mobility it's this guy he
only has one square but after this
exchange two three four and this is the
one that I ended up making use of and
the one where I was having you you know
a move I ended up making you react to
but if you keep this tension what do I
do in the meantime let's see let's say
you play your knight here what might be
a common move to see
Bishop e7 well now if you go ahead and
capture and I recapture if I'm really
wanting to make use of b4 I'm having to
take an extra step I'm having to take an
extra move
additionally should you play Knight f3
here and I go with g6 I'm doing that so
I can feed and cut on my bishop
if you then capture then again it's
meaningless to play here I'm having to
take two steps so just be a bit more
patient keep the tension in the center
in other words if you do get to this
point but my earliest suggestion is to
maybe look into that d5 move okay it
does allow for my knight to maybe make
use of this square you could be
defending against that just more
development III still night out but look
into d5 look into not capturing in this
position as well okay